my guest tonight of course won an Emmy
Award for his portrayal of Jack
McFarland on the hit series Will and
Grace he's got a new movie out he wrote
and he stars in it it's called lazy
susan it's available on video on demand
April 3rd and this is a good time to be
watching video on demand please welcome
our really good friend mr. Sean Hayes
Sean thanks for being here thank you do
I hold for the applause like are you
gonna put the applause in there will be
no applause oh so we just go right into
it yeah you know the way normally
there'd be some applause for you sure
now there's just nothing I'm kind of
used to it
I know people like you and I are similar
in that we both the times that you and I
have gotten together and like had dinner
we're both doing bits the whole time you
know people like us who have to be
quarantined yeah I'm performing for like
pillows yeah I feel like I've trained my
mind and body to be quarantined my whole
life oh really yeah so it's finally
paying off so you're saying you were
socially distant saying since when what
my whole well you know this virus has
caused us to be socially distant I'm
actually waiting for the virus that
causes us to be emotionally distant I
think I caught it a long time ago you
got that around like nine years old you
think mm-hmm I was like that and he just
gave it to me have you guys been fate
going on you know whatever facetiming
yeah well you know who knew what zoom
was until this started right did you see
that video that went viral about no pun
intended that this woman was and like
I'm meeting a zoom meeting with all of
her co-workers and she took the day but
I've heard about it tell me I was like
you know there's like 50 windows open
and she literally just takes her laptop
and walks all the way to the bathroom
pulls her pants down and goes to the
bathroom
and first of all there's so many things
to break that let's break that down one
bringing a laptop into the bathroom at
any point your life yeah yeah
why are you doing it during an office
meeting
Bird Lake and then and then it's really
asked up that her that somebody recorded
it and then posted it oh my god yeah
yeah there's so many things wrong with
it the Tiger King makes more sense than
this no I was the way everyone's
enjoying Tiger King right now how could
you not did you watch the whole thing I
haven't watched the whole thing yet I'm
but halfway through I love it is
astonishing it's a shame
it's still not as good as someone taking
their laptop in